hello oh god to help us out oh god
lawson has a collaboration with how do
you pronounce this good either good
either good idea
it's a god of old god either i think
it's gotta be right no one knows
so they have like their own collection
of like i'm honestly
not gonna chocolates it looks [ __ ]
honestly any time they have so family
mart
or lawson's wait give me that what's it
called that's [ __ ]
curry oh what it's karepa is that curry
bread
it's curry bread oh no oh no this is
chocolate bread
this is beef curry bread in a chocolate
bun
yo crack that open let's give it a shot
let's give it a shot okay
okay this is this is gonna be a trash
case first here
why because i have literally never
that looks like a donut it's like it
looks like curry bread but
with it's if it's like made out of
chocolate okay so open up a napkin and
rip that [ __ ] over so to explain what
curry bread is normally like
it's literally you take japanese curry
and then you deep fry it
in the katsu right and uh cuts your
bread and then
it's it's kind of it's kind of like a
jelly filled doughnut except imagine the
filling
was curry yeah that's correct and it's
[ __ ] good it's great curry normal
curry bread is [ __ ] amazing
this is not normal this is
an abomination i'm excited to i'm
actually excited because
i want to know what the [ __ ] is going on
yeah like how is the synergy of
chocolate and cucumber
if i like this what does that mean okay
i would say for um experience points
one of the worst combinations i've had
was when i went to the wisconsin state
fair
in the usa and they were and they were
selling
uh chocolate bacon they would literally
take bacon
and dip it in chocolate i'm go i'm about
to find out if
there is a worse combination right now
than chocolate bacon
i don't know chocolate bacon sounds
[ __ ] horrible okay well chocolate
curry bread
that also sounds horrible all right oh
okay look at that okay so
it looks like it literally looks like a
curry in between chocolate bread
that smells like a just a contradiction
you know let's give it a bite let's
fight into it boys
oh it's [ __ ] up that's [ __ ] up that
ain't right no
i don't like that um do you like that
joey
i kind of like it no wait
no that's awful oh that's all that is so
awful oh my god
oh my god i don't know if i'm just
[ __ ] up but that just tastes like
curry
bread to me no it tastes what are you
talking about i i legitimately can't
taste the chocolate i can't taste the
chocolate all i get is like a weird
bitter aftertone it's it's even worse
than chocolate bread because it's not
even sweet
it's the you can taste the cocoa in the
chocolate
and then you bite into it and then you
get a mouthful of curry
it's the worst it's an aftertaste that
you sh
this is i like legitimately can't taste
the chocolate yeah i taste
do you taste the cocoa though right no i
bet with this one it's going to be rich
this is the chocolate bread and it's
their collaboration with godivo
oh god that get that away from me i
literally feel
to me that just tastes like a curry
bread sorry i liked it
oh
yeah yeah that was heavy that's that's
how chocolate look should look like
chocolate breads yes
dude i get like a nosebleed after eating
one piece of good eye over chocolate let
alone this whole [ __ ] bread the
chocolate bread which actually
looks pretty [ __ ] good that looks
good that's because they're not being
adventurous with [ __ ] curry bread
yeah if there's one thing you shouldn't
put in chocolate bread it's curry
it's a nice cross section we've got some
oh god that is
very strong chocolate paste on chocolate
bread it just smells like heaven
a whiff sorry oh that's chocolate
[ __ ] that's really good honestly a
little disappointed really okay no
no you don't like that i really like it
the bread the chocolate tastes
very artificial the chocolate tastes
good i don't like the bread
that tastes not as good as like it it's
chewy bread as well it's not the
fluffy bread chewy bread doesn't taste
good with the chocolate that they put in
there
i'll [ __ ] with it joey you [ __ ] with
enemy anything joey
i do is that [ __ ] weird i [ __ ] with
that yeah
is it like what is this is this seasoned
vomit i mean i'm gonna try it
oh okay i mean i i'm [ __ ] i'd [ __ ]
with that i'm the kind of guy who's like
i don't want to
offend anyone so if i went to another
country and they're like oh this is what
we eat
and i just vomit with seasoning i'd be
like well i mean
i you know i don't want to offend anyone
so i'll give it a shot yeah
i mean i'll be like it's great yeah you
don't have to like it
at all yeah just trying it just trying
it i think is like more of an
appreciation to the culture then
honestly anything else
what was presented here was a massive
disappointment from
the usual kind of it looks like sex yeah
this looks like sex
it tastes like it should be like [ __ ]
amazing and how many calories is this
bad boy
254 calories uh 31 grams of
sugar carbohydrates and 29 grams of
sugar so damn
the black sugar poop pieces were more
less healthier than that
yeah i know